[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره تردنا من
العاصمه السودانيه بعد اطلاق نار وتحليق
للطيران الحربي في الخرطوم وام درمان
بينما تقترب هدنه الايام السبعه من
نهايتها
هذه الصور مباشره من السويد من تحديدا حيث
بدات فعاليات مؤتمر مؤتمر فلسطيني اوروبا
تحت شعار خمسه وسبعون سنه انا لعائدون
وتتضمن الفعاليات على مدى يوم كامل علاقه
اوروبا بالسرديه الفلسطينيه
وهذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من كان حيث
تختتم مساء اليوم الدوره السادسه والسبعون
لمهرجان كان السينمائي ومن المنتظر ان
تعلن قائمه الافلام الفائزه خلال الحفل
النهائي
[موسيقى]
ومن مهرجان كان السينمائي الى مواضيع
الحصاد لهذه الليله
وسط صمت اوكراني كثافه في الهجمات داخل
روسيا
موسكو تعلن تعرض مصفاه نفط قرب الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا لهجوم بالمسيرات ومقتل مدنيا في
تصاعد للقصف على
تقول ان اوكرانيا طلبت تزويدها بصواريخ
كروز يصل مداها الى 500 كيلومتر
مراسل الجزيره يرصد الاوضاع في مطار
الخرطوم الذي كان ساحه قتال منذ اليوم
الاول للمعارك وقبل انقضاء الهدنه اطلاق
نار متفرق وتحليق لطائرات الحربيه في
العاصمه السودانيه واشتباكات عنيفه في
نيالا والفاشر غربا وبالتزامن مع اول
اجتماع لمجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي بشان
الازمه نائب البرهان يدعو لعمليه سلام
جاده داخل البيت الافريقي وموسى فكي يشدد
على توحيد الجهود الدوليه برعايه افريقيه
لحل النزاع
عشيه اول جوله اعاده تشهدها تركيا في
انتخابات الرئاسه اردوغان يختتم حملته
بزياره ضريح اول رئيس وزراء اطيح به في
انقلاب عسكري ويدعو الى مشاركه كثيفه
لحمايه البلاد عبر الديمقراطيه ومنافسه
كالجدار اوغلو يهاجم الاداء الاقتصادي
للحكومه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا عقد مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي اجتماعا اليوم على مستوى رؤساء
الدول والحكومات لبحث الازمه السودانيه
والذي اكد فيه رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي موسى فكي انه لا حل عسكريا
للازمه في السودان لاستطاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم ما فرص حل ازمه السودان
داخل البيت الافريقي 30% قالوا ان الفرص
كبيره بينما 20% قالوا ان الفرصه ضئيله
اما 50% فراوا الا فرص اطلاقا لحل ازمه
السودان داخل البيت الافريقي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا حذر وترقب في
البلقان بعد اعلان الصربيا ابقاء الجيش في
حاله تاهب قصوى للجيش بعد صدامات بين
متظاهرين الصرب والشرطه شماليه
[موسيقى]
نبدا من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فيما بدا
انه تغير في نسق الحرب اشتدت اليوم
الهجمات داخل العمق الروسي وسط صمت
اوكراني فقد اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بسكوف
الروسيه انه هجوما بمسيارتين ملغمتين
استهدف محطه لتكرير النفط في المقاطعه من
جهه اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيل غورود الروسيه
مقتل مدنيا في قصف مدفعي اوكراني لمدينه
شبينكو الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا هذا وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه انها تلقت طلبا من
اوكرانيا بتسليمها صواريخ كروز من طراز
تاوروس يصل مداها الى 500 كلم
اسبوع هو الاطول على روسيا ربما منذ بدات
حملتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا في فبراير من
العام الماضي اسبوع تغير فيه اتجاه
الهجمات من الغرب الى الشرق اخر هذه
الهجمات ما اعلنه حاكم منطقه بيسكوف
الروسيه عن هجوم بمسييرتين ملاغمتين
استهدف محطه لتكرير النفط تمد خط دركبه
ضخم الذي ينقل النفط الخامه من سيبيريا
نحو اوروبا الهجوم الذي اوقع اضرارا في
ثلاثه مباني اداريه في المحطه وقع حسب
الروايه الروسيه في منطقه مثلث الحدود بين
روسيا وبيلاروسيا ولاتفيا وتبعد مسافه 600
كم عن الحدود مع اوكرانيا وتلك مسافه
بعيده لكن بالقرب من الحدود مع اوكرانيا
تحدثت المصادر الروسيه عن قصف المدفعي
الاوكراني طالم مقاطعه
في خامس هجوم تتهم موسكو كييف بالمسؤوليه
عنه خلال اقل من اسبوع تصير السلطات
الاوكرانيه على اكيد انما يجري في بيل
جرود وفي عموم التراب الروسي شان داخلي
وتنفي اي علاقه لها بما يجري من جهتها
تمضي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في اتهام
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت انها اعترضت صاروخين
من طراز كروز بعيد المدى من طراز ستورم
شادو التي كانت بريطانيا قد قدمته
لاوكرانيا وفي الخامس والعشرين من هذا
الشهر اتهم جهاز امن الدوله الروسي من
وصفه بالمخربين الاوكرانيين بمحاوله تخريب
محطتين نوويتين غرب البلاد استهداف
المحطتين النوويتين جاء بعد اقل من يوم
واحد على تعرض السفينه الحربيه الروسيه
ايفانخورس لما قالت موسكو انه هجوم الفاشل
من ثلاثه زوارق مسيره الاوكرانيه في البحر
الاسود بالقرب من مضيق الفوسفور وهو ما
اعلنت كيف لاحقا المسؤوليه عنه
سبق ذلك بيوم واحد هجوم مجموعات عسكريه
اوكرانيه ذات توجه قومي كما وصفته موسكو
على مقاطعه بيلكرود باستخدام معدات عسكريه
غربيه الصنع بينما قال ما يسمى بفيلق
المتطوعين الروس انه نفذ عمليه ناجحه في
المنطقه ورغم غموض التصريحات الاوكرانيه
بشان عدد من هذه الهجمات خصوصا ما اذا
كانت تندرج في اطار هجومها المضاد الذي
تقول احيانا انه بدا واحيانا اخرى انه
وشيك فان الحرب بين الطرفين كما تبدو من
بعيد قد دخلت مرحله جديده مع تطلع
اوكرانيا للحصول على طائرات اف 16 وحديث
برلين عن تلقيها طلبا من الكيف للحصول على
صواريخ كروز تطلق من الجو ويبلغ مداها 500
كلم
[موسيقى]
صواريخ وتاوروس التي تطلبها كييف من برلين
تنتجه شركتان واحده المانيه والاخرى
سويديه وبدا انتاجها عام 2004 يبلغ وزن
الصاروخ 1400 كيلوغرام وحصلت جيوش المانيا
واسبانيا وكوريا الجنوبيه على دفعه منه
اما طوله فيصل الى سته امتار مع عرض
جناحين يصل مترين ونصف المتر يحمل راسا
متفجرا يصل وزنها الى 481 كلغ وقد حصلت
المانيا على 600 صاروخ تاوروس عام 2010 في
صفقه بلغت قيمتها اكثر من 600 مليون دولار
ينضم الينا من كييف يوري ساك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع مرحبا بك
هل بدا الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني المنتظر
نحن قلنا عده مرات ان الهجمات المضاده
والتي ربما ينبغي ان نسميها هجوما لان
الروس لم يحققوا اي نجاح في ساحات المعارك
لفتره طويله من الزمن وهو كون انه هجوم لن
يبدا بالضروره في ساعه معينه او في يوم
معين انما هو سلسله من العمليات العسكريه
المعقده المختلفه في درجاته وشداتها بعضها
له طابع تمهيدي وقد بدا ذلك بالفعل ومستمر
وقيادتنا العسكريه تقيم الاوضاع يوميا في
ساحات المعارك كما قالت قيادتنا العسكريه
العليا قد تتخذ خطوات وقرارات فورا ما ترى
ان ذلك مناسب في ميدان المعركه لاننا لا
المخاطره بحياتي جنودنا ان كانت المجازفه
والمخاطره كبيره لهذا السبب انه نجري
حساباتنا ونقيم هجمات في عده جبهات ونهيئ
في نفس الوقت للمراحل التاليه من الهجمات
هذه الهجمات التمهيديه كما وصفتها السيد
جوري هي التي تحدث ونشهد نشهدها في داخل
الاراضي الروسيه
بالطبع لا ما نراه وما نراه جميعنا داخل
روسيا وداخل الاراضي الروسيه هي عمليات
معينه
ونشاط معينه من قبل افراد مواطنون روس
ووفقا لبياناتهم الرسميه هم يريدون التخلص
من نظام الكرملين لانهم يختلفون مع جرائم
الحرب والفضائع التي ارتكبها
والبؤس الذي يتسبب به النظام هناك عندما
نتحدث عن هجماتنا المضاده وهنا نقصد بها
الهجمات التي تحدث حوالي مدينه مخموت
مارينكا وغيرها بشكل عام نفهم المقصود هو
الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله مؤقتا وليس
الاراضي الروسيه طيب سيدي قائد القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه يقول اليوم في تصريح
لقد حان الوقت ان نستعيد ما لنا ويتزامن
ذلك كذلك مع نشر فيديو عبر منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي من جانب وزاره الدفاع يظهر
الاستعدادات لهذا الهجوم المضاد ماذا نفهم
من كل ذلك
على الجميع ان يفهم ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيات تهيئ للمرحله التاليه من
تحرير اراضينا وبشكل يومي في اوكرانيا وفي
بلدان اخرى كما تعلمون فان حلفاء لا
يقدمون الدعم لنا ايضا اذا هناك الالاف من
الجنود الاوكرانيين يخضعون لتدريبات
عسكريه في بلدان اخرى حليفه لنا مثل
المملكه المتحده ايطاليا اسبانيا بولندا
وغيرها فنحن اذا نتهيا لتحرير ارضنا هذا
ما يعنيه هذا القول ولكن ايضا هناك من
يتهم الطرف الاوكراني بان كل ذلك ياتي في
اطار الدعايه ورفع المعنويات بعد الخصال
الكبير التي منيتم بها في باخ متر رغم كل
هذا الدعم الغربي الذي تتحدث عنه
اعتقد ان الدعايه هي
السرديه التي تقول اننا خسرنا خساره كبيره
في باخماط بخموت هي المدينه التي لم يستطع
الروس السيطره عليها لفتره طويله لاكثر من
عشره اشهر مخموطي المدينه التي خسر فيها
الجيش الروسي ما يقرب من مئه الف جندي
بخموت هي مدينه القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تسيطر على الاجزاء الغربيه منها اذا انا
لا ادري اي مصادر تستندون اليها عندما
تقولون اننا منينه بهزيمه في ضخمه نحن
ندافع بشكل بطولي وما زلنا في الجزء
الجنوبي من المدينه شكرا لك يوريساك
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني والمتحدث
باسمي وزاره الدفاع ضيفنا من كييف
ومن موسكو ينضم الينا فلاديمير يرى نوسيان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد
فلاديمير اذا اوكرانيا بدات بالفعل سلسله
من العمليات العسكريه المعقده ذات الطابع
التمهيدي
ايزانا ببدء الهجوم المضاد على روسيا هل
روسيا مستعده لذلك
طوال هذا الوقت طوال العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه القوات الروسيه حضرت الكثير من
القدرات الدفاعيه وفي نفس الوقت كانت تقوم
باعمال استراتيجيه ومنظمه في الجبهات
كنا قد حررنا باخ موت والان نسميه
هناك قضينا على عدد كبير من الجنود
الاوكرانيين منهم القوات الخاصه
ومجموعات مختلفه كانت
مسؤوله عن التجسس التابعه لوزاره الدفاع
وكانت تابعه لواشنطن اما بالنسبه للهجمات
على العمق
الروسي بمسافه خمس كيلو مترات كما يسم
المتطوعون الروس هذا هذه الفرقه هي جزء من
العمل الاستخباراتي الاوكراني وليس لهم
ليس لهم اي صله للشعب الروسي
بالكثير منهم مئه خائن ومنهم سبعين شخص
قتل اثناء هذه الهجمات
الهجمات التي كانت عباره عن سيطره على
منزلين قرويين اما بالنسبه للعمليات
العكسيه سيد فلاديمير هذه المجموعات هذه
المجموعات وانت تقول ان المخبرات
الاوكرانيه تقف وراءها نجحت حتى الان في
القيام بعدد من العمليات في الداخل الروسي
كيف ستتعامل روسيا مع هذا الامر وقد
انتقلت بعض العمليات الى داخل اراضيها
روسيا لاكثر من مره في تاريخها تعرضت
لهجمات ارهابيه من قبل مختلف المنظمات
الارهابيه واليوم نحن نتعرض لارهاب من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه حيث يحضر التخريبيين
ثم يرسلوهم عن طريق الحدود ليس هناك اي
نجاح استراتيجي او عملياته عدا عن ذلك
انهم يقتلوا اذا ما تذكرنا التسعينيات كان
من الاصعب القضاء على التخريبيين
والجماعات الارهابيه في الشيشان اما الان
قمنا بهذا بيوم ونصف
خلال اليوم والنصف
قمنا
بالقضاء على جميع هؤلاء المخربين وحايدنا
الخطر الذي
ظهر منهم طيب الان كيف تستعد كما ذكر
ضيفنا قبل قليل مستشار وزير الدفاع تستعد
لهذا الهجوم المضاد وهناك دعم المزيد من
الدعم من دول الغرب لها والمزيد من
الاسلحه المتطوره كذلك
يتحدث رئيس الاركان عن استعاده اوكرانيا
لما لها من اراض كيف تقراون المرحله
المقبله في ضوء كل ذلك
الاسلحه التي تصل لاوكرانيا هي
اسلحه اقل مما يحتاجون بكثير حتى الاسلحه
الثقيله مثل الدبابات
تاتيهم بكميات مثل
وروسيا لديها اسلحه اكثر
بالعدد
وبعشرات المرات اعني هنا المعدات الثقيله
والمدرعات اما بالنسبه
للاسلحه التي كانت تصل
من منظومات المضادات نعلم ان لدينا انظمه
رادارات تستطيع ان تحايد صواريخ
الهايمرز
وتقوم برصدها
واما صواريخ
فهي غير كافيه ونحن نستطيع ان نسقطها
بنجاح وقواتنا
الجويه
لديها قدرات دقيقه جدا تقوم بتدمير اي
صواريخ مجنحه وتقصف ايضا المنظومات
الدفاعيه الجويه نعلم اننا دمرنا منظومه
الامريكيه شكرا لك يا فلاديمير ناسويان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
وننوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل مشاهدينا قوه
الدعم السريع تقول انه ملتزمه باتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار وانا على استعداد كامل لبحث
امكانيه تجديده
تمكنت الجزيره من دخول مطار الخرطوم الذي
كان مسرحا للمعارك منذ اليوم الاول
لاندلاع القتال بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في منتصف ابريل نيسان
الماضي وظهرت الصور الحصريه توقفا كاملا
لعمل المطار ومرافقه ومنشاته وغياب
الموظفين والعاملين به كما اظهرت طائره
ظهرت طائره محترقه واضرارا لحقت بالمعدات
والاجهزه ووجود بعض القذائف داخل المطار
كما سمعت اصوات اطلاق نار متقطع قرب
المطار خلال تجوال فريق الجزيره في بعض
منشاته ورصد مراسل الجزيره مخازن الاغذيه
الملحقه بالمطار ومنطقه تخزين امتعه
المسافرين وهي في حاله من الفوضى
وبينما تقترب هدنه الايام السبعه من
نهايتها شهدت الخرطوم وام درمان اطلاق نار
متفرقا وتحليقا للطيران الحربي كما شهدت
مدينه نيالا والفاشر غربا تجددا
للاشتباكات وبالتزامن مع اول اجتماع لمجلس
الامن والسلم الافريقي بشان الازمه دعا
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني مالك
عقار الى عمليه سلام جاده داخل البيت
الافريقي بينما شدد رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي موسى فكي على توحيد الجهود
الدوليه برعايه افريقيه لحل النزاع
لا يزال البحث جاريا في اتجاهات مختلفه عن
سبل انهاء الحرب الدائره في السودان منذ
منتصف الشهر الماضي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريعه حسب مراسل الجزيره يسود هدوء حذر
مختلفه جبهات القتال بموجب الهدنه المبرمه
اخيرا في جده ببساطه سعوديه امريكيه وان
كانت الطرفانيه
بخرقها وكما هو الحال في اغلب الايام تحلق
الطائرات الحربيه في سماء الخرطوم وام
درمان دون اي تفاصيل تتعلق بتبادل القصف
المكثف الذي ظل سائدا سوى سماع اصوات
اطلاق نار متقطع في جنوب غرب مدينه ام
درمان الجديد الان هو دخول الاتحاد
الافريقي في جهود البحث عن حل يوقف الحرب
رئيس المفوضيه الاتحاد موسى فقي جدد دعوه
الطرفين يوم السبت لوقف الحرب دون قيد او
شرط لكنه لم يطرح الاجتماعي مجلس الامن
والسلم الافريقي المنعقد في اديس ابابا اي
رؤيه لتحقيق ذلك وركز موسى فكي خلال حديثه
على معاناه المدنيين ودمائهم المسفوكه
ودعا للمره الاولى الى اشراكهم في اي
مفاوضات لوقف اطلاق النار كما شدد على
تنسيق اي جهود لوقف الحرب برعايه الاتحاد
الافريقي وطالب بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن
الانتهاكات التي حدثت بموجب القوانين
الدوليه المتعلقه بحقوق الانسان
طبعا من المبكر جدا الحديث عن من يحاسب
وعلى ماذا يحاسب وكيف يتحقق ذلك والحرب لم
تضع اوزارها بعد ويصر طرفاها على انها حرب
من اجل السودانيين والديمقراطيه في
السودان تجري هذه التطورات بعد يوم واحد
من طلب رئيس مجلس السياده والقائد العام
للجيش السوداني الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان
من الامين العام للامم المتحده تغيير
مبعوثه الخاص في السودان
وطالما اشتكى البرهان وقاده سياسيون
السودانيون اخرون من تدخل في شؤون داخليه
لا ينبغي التدخل فيها لكنها المره الاولى
التي يصرح فيها البرهان بان قوات الدعم
السريع ما كانت تجرا على خوض هذه الحرب
لولا تشجيع
الثابت ان خطوطا كثيره داخليه تتقاطع حتى
الان مع اليهود المبذوله من اجل ايجاد حل
ولا يدري احد كيفيه الوصول لذلك من بين
هذه الخيوط وهو ما يبقي الامور كما كانت
دائما مفتوحه على مختلف الاحتمالات
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي السوداني
مرحبا بك سيد ضياء كيف يمكن تقييم خطوات
مجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي هذا اول
اجتماع للمجلس على مستوى الرؤساء منذ
اندلاع هذه الازمه في السودان
واضح ان هنالك تنافس ما بين مبادرات
مختلفه اذا كانت المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه او المبادره الافريقيه وحتى في
المبادره الافريقيه كانت هنالك بدايه بان
تكون
هنالك اجتماع لسلاسه دول اعتقد ان اثيوبيا
وكينيا ودوله ثالثه ولكن هذه الاتفاق هذه
المبادرات وجهت بالاحتراط خاصه هنالك
تشكيك في الدور الكيني من قبل الحكومه
السودانيه للعلاقات التي تربط الرئيس
الكيني
بالحميتي في وقت سابق فاعتقد ان التعدد
هذه المبادرات
يساهم في استطاله
مدى الزمني للحرب ويتيح مساحتها واسعه
للمناوره السياسيه من قبل الطرفين فمن
الاولى ان تكون هنالك مبادره متفقه عليها
مبادره اقليميه دوليه عربيه تشارك فيها
الجامعه العربيه ويشارك فيها الاتحاد
الافريقي ويكون هنالك وجود للامم المتحده
هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي ولكن هذا التنافس
والتجاذب
سيسهم في اطاله مدى الحرب ولن يسهم كثيرا
في تحقيق
والتقارب ما بين الاطراف في جميع النواحي
كيف وجدت هذا التصريح الاخير للنائب رئيس
مجلس السياده الذي يتحدث عن ضروره ايجاد
عمليه سياسيه جاده في داخل البيت الافريقي
بهذا المعنى يعني ما الذي يفهم من وراء
هذا الكلام ونحن عشيه ربما يعني انتهاء
الهدنه التي تم التوصل اليها
بمبادره سعوديه امريكيه نعم هذه هي امانه
وتطلعات عدد من الاطراف بان يظل البيت
الافريقي هو
الحاصل لهذه النزاعات ولكن البيت الافريقي
للاسف فيه كثير من من التجاذبات كذلك
واكفي كثير من القصور في التعامل والتفاعل
مع الازمه السودانيه حتى في طورها الاول
وتدخلت الامم المتحده عبر البحصه البحصه
الامميه فكل التجارب المتعلقه بالاتحاد
الافريقي لم تكن مثمره ولا مديه يمكن ان
ننظر الى التجربه الاثيوبيه الاتحاد
الافريقي لم يستطع ان يتدخل بشكل حاسم في
التجربه الاثيوبيه الحرب الاثيوبيه الى
بعد ان تغيرت موازين القوى لمصلحه الحكومه
الاثيوبيه فهنالك شكوك تحيط بامكانيه
ومغدره الاتحاد الافريقي ومقدره الدول
الافريقيه في حل النزاعات الطبيعه
الافريقيه لذلك تتدخل اطراف دوليه حينما
تنظر وترى ان الاتحاد الافريقي والدور
الافريقيه لهم عجز وعدم مقدره على التعامل
مع الاشكالات داخل البيت الافريقي الان
هنالك مبادره تمضي هي المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه او تجد دعم من الامور المتحده
وتجد الرضا وقبول قبل الطرفين
اسفلت عن وقف اطلاق ناري سبعه ايام رغم ان
يعني الاشتباكات مستمره واليوم توسعت
وهناك طيران حربي وما الى هنالك ولكن الان
الهدنه يفترض ان تنتهي مساء الاثنين ماذا
بعد ذلك باعتقادك ما الذي يحضر له قد تقول
هنالك هدنه ولكن الهدنه بالمعنى الاصطلاحي
لها بان تتوقف العمليات العسكريه مع
الاحتفاظ باجواء الحرب لا اعتقد انها
اعتقد انها تطبق في كثير من المرات تتجاوز
الثمانيه مرات كانت هنالك هدنه ولكن كانت
هنالك عمليات عسكريه في اماكن متعدده
وكثيره واليوم هنالك عمليات عسكريه تمتد
من الفاشر الى ام درمان الى الخرطوم الى
بحري فواضح ان هنالك عدم التزام لان قوه
الدعم السريع الاساسيه ليست لها متحكم
ليست هنالك سيطره سيطره ميدانيه على هذه
التحركات لذلك تحولت هذه المجموعات الى
مجموعات
مجموعات نهبه وسلب ومجموعات تقوم ببعض
التصرفات الخارجه عن كل الاجنده السياسيه
التي يمكن ان تنظر بان الدعم السريع يسعى
اليها فبالتالي هذا هذا العجز عن اداره
وضبط تحركات
القوات الدعم السريع يمثل منافذ للخرق
الدائم لكل الهدن التي يتم الاتفاق عليها
من جميع الاطراف اشكرك جزيل الشكر بلال
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي السوداني
ضيفنا هنا في استديو الحصاد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
يتواصل التصعيد بين كوسوفو والصربيا حيث
اعلن مجلس الامن الصربي ان الجيش ما يزال
في حاله تاهب قصوى وارجع بيان صدر عن
المجلس بعد اجتماعه اليوم هذا القرار الى
ما وصفه بالاستخدام الوحشي للقوه ضد
الاقليه الصربيه في شمال كوسوفو وقال مجلس
الامن الصربي ان قوه حفظ السلام في كوسوفو
التي يقودها النيتو لم تقم بعملها وانا
الرئيس اركان الجيش الصربي مفوض بالحفاظ
على الاتصال المباشر مع قائد هذه القوه
للنظر في ذلك
ياتي ذلك بعد اندلاع المواجهات بين الشرطه
في كوسوفو ومواطنين من اصول صربيه احرقت
فيها سيارات للشرطه في البلدات الشماليه
على الحدود مع صربيا وقالت الشرطه في بيان
انها تتخذ اجراءات وتدابير لمنع جميع
الانشطه الاجراميه في البلد وتقدم
المساعده لبلديات في الشمال
نقلت وكاله سبوتنيك عن مسؤول بارز في
الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو ستواصل دعم
صربيا في حمايه حقوقها وسيادتها وسلامه
اراضيها وشدد على ان اي قرار بشان كوسوفو
يجب ان يكون مقبولا بالنسبه للصلب ويوافق
عليه مجلس الامن الدولي من جانبها قالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
خروف ان موسكو تراقب بقلق تدهور الاوضاع
في اقليم كوسوفو وانها تدين بشده خطوات
بريجتين الاستفزازيه التي جعلت الوضع
يقترب من المرحله الساخنه ويهدد بشكل
مباشر ان المنطقه منطقه البلقان باكملها
حسب تعبيرها وحملت زخاروفا الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي المسؤوليه عن
ذلك
في الاثناء حث حلف شمال الاطلسي كوسوفو
على تخفيف التوتر مع صربيا ودعت المتحدثه
باسم الحلف وانا في تغريده المؤسسات في
كوسوفو الى تهدئه فورا والعمل على حل
الازمه عبر الحوار
في ملف كوسوفو وصربيا سيكون لنا بعد قليل
حديث معمق وموسع عن خلفيات التوتر بين
البلدين
[موسيقى]
الان الى تغطيتنا الخاصه للمشهد التركي
قبل ساعات من جوله حسم الرئاسه
[موسيقى]
دخلت تركيا مرحله الصمت الانتخابيه عند
السادسه من مساء اليوم قبل ذلك قام الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بزياره ضريح رئيس
الوزراء السابق عدنان مندريس الذي حكم
واعدم بعد انقلاب عسكريا ضده عام 1960
وقال الرئيس التركي خلال زياره في ذكرى
ذلك الانقلاب ان زمن الانقلابات العسكريه
قد ولى وطالب الاتراك بالتوجه بكثافه الى
صناديق الاقتراع لحمايه استقلال البلاد
عبر الديمقراطيه
نقف اليوم في ذكرى احد اكثر الايام حركه
في تاريخ جمهوريتنا ففي مثل هذا اليوم قبل
63 عاما تعرضت تركيا لاول انقلاب عسكري في
تاريخها لم يحرم شعبنا من الديمقراطيه
والتنميه فقط بل ترك ايضا جرحا غائرا في
قلوبنا نؤكد ان التصويت الكبير وحجم
المشاركه في الانتخابات يؤكد حرص امتنا
على حمايه مستقبلها واستقلالها عبر
الديمقراطيه
من جهته وجه مرشح مرشح وتحالف الشعب
التركي كمال كل جدار اوغلو في العاصمه
انقره انتقادات للحكومه بسبب ادائها
الاقتصادي الذي وصفه بالضعيف والذي اضر
بالعائلات التركيه ومنعها من تقديم الغذاء
الصحي والرعايه لاطفالها على حد تعبيره
سنين
على الدوله ان تكون اجتماعيه وان تقف الى
جانب العائلات هذه وظيفه الدوله وليس
الافراد والمنظمات على الدوله الاجتماعيه
الا تترك عائلاتها في عوز للاخر وعليها ان
تنشئ الحضانات لصالح الامهات العاملات في
الاحياء الفقيره لان ذلك من مميزات الدوله
الاجتماعيه عند وصولنا للحكم سنمنح كل
عائله محتاجه مبلغا شهريا ونعد بعدم قطع
خدمات الماء والكهرباء او الغاز عن اي
عائله محتاجه في تركيا
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول جيهون بوسكورت
الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي ومن ازمير
معنى ديليك كابي الكاتب الصحفيه والمحلله
السياسيه مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك السيده
ديليك هل هناك امكانيه لحدوث مفاجات غدا
هناك مفاجات غدا نعم لان المرحله كانت
محتذبه جدا من حيث المنافسه وكما تعلمون
قد تم اجراء الجوله الاولى في الخامس عشر
من الشهر الجائري وكانت هناك كان هناك
تقارب بين اصوات المرشحين
وبالتالي نجي نشهد الان مرحله
انتخابيه
بها منافسه شرسه ولا شك ان كلا المرشحين
قد نعم رفع من سقف ايضا الوعود وكذلك
نستطيع ان نقول انه هناك منافسه وعديه
واضحه جدا في الحمله الانتخابيه الاخيره
واعتقد وفقا لذلك سنجد نتائج تنعكس على
صناديق الاقتراع ما رايك سيد جيهون
بوسكورت هل المجال مفتوح باعتقادك غدا
ربما لمفاجاه ام ان الامور تبدو شبه
محسومه
سيتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع من جديد يمكن
ان تكون النتائج نعم مفاجاه ربما اي نتائج
يمكن ان نتوقعها ولكن كيف الميول العامه
نعم عندما ننظر الى
توجه عام لدى الناخبين نرى بان الرئيس
اردوغان قد ناشد مؤيديه بانه يجب عليه ان
يتمسكوا بصنادق الاختراع ولا يتهاون ولا
يتراخوا بسبب
فوز فوزه في الجوله الاولى ولكن يؤكد ايضا
على انتصاره من ناحيه اخرى
وبينما نرى
الناخبين الذين ايدوا
هم كذلك
يتمسكون
بخيارهم الديمقراطي وسيتوجهون الى صناديق
الاقتراع وذلك من اجل السعي الى احتمال ان
ينتصر
التحالفهم على اردوغان
[موسيقى]
وان لم
استطيع ان نجزم ونقول ولكن يمكن ان نتنبا
من الان بالقول بان الرئيس اردوغان هو من
سيفوز في الجوله الثانيه ولكن ليس بشكل
حاسم
ونرى بانها
اذا ما نظرنا الى ايضا ما تداولته وسائل
الاعلام الغربيه في المانيا وفي انجلترا
وفي فرنسا
ونجد بان كانت هناك هجمات شرسه ضده
اردوغان خلال الحملات الانتخابيه
الماضيه ولكن راينا بان الرئيس اردوغان
استطاع ان يتصدى لكل ذلك وخيب الامال
واستطاع ان يتقدم في الجوله الاولى لذلك
نجد ان الان التقدم السيكولوجي ربما لصالح
اردوغان ولكن يمكن ان تكون هناك مفاجات
ايضا
[موسيقى]
من جرعه
التحفيز القومي بانجاز التعبير في خطابه
في بعد المرحله الاولى من الانتخابات وعقد
تحالفات جديده لاسيما مع اوميت اوزداغ كيف
من شان ذلك باعتقادك ان يؤثر على
القاعده الناخبه
[موسيقى]
فيديو
تغيرات في المعادلات بعد الجوله
الاولى كان هناك مرشح ثالث
حيث حصل على خمسه بالمئه من مجموع الاصوات
وبالتالي الان ظهرت معادلات جديده
وبالتالي اصبحت ورقه الورقه القوميه هي
الورقه الرابحه ربما لذلك
الان هناك مقاربه سياسيه جديده
نحو الترويج للقوميه
ولكن ايضا
من ناحيه اخرى نرى ان هناك تحديات ومشاكل
حقيقيه في تركيا من بينها مشكله اللاجئين
ومشكله اللاجئين ربما كانت سببا في تنام
ظاهره القوميه في تركيا
وبالتالي هذا الامر سيؤثر على نتائج
الانتخابات في الجوله الثانيه
براينا واصبح اللسان حادا لدى الطرفين
والرئيس
التحالفين كان يتجنبان
عن استخدام السنه واساليب شديده اللهجه
للترويج للقوميه في واقي الامر ولكن لما
بدا الاقتراب من الجوله الثانيه اصبح
الاسلوب متغيرا
وبالتالي
اعتقد ان
سيتم ربما التمسك بالديمقراطيه ولكن يجب
ان لا ننسى ان هناك تصاعدا قوميا او توجها
قوميا متصاعدا في تركيا
وبالتالي لابد من فهم واستيعاب الشعب بشكل
جدا ومع التازر مع الشعب وفهم ايضا معاناه
الشعب واعتقد ان الطرف الذي يستطيع ان
يبدي هذه المشاعر تجاهها الناخبينه ومن
سيفوز في الجوله الثانيه
فاذاجحون على ماذا يعول الرئيس التركي
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان في زياده نسبه
المصوتين لصالحه في الدوره الثانيه هذه
المره
اذا ما نظرنا الى نسبه
سنان اوران
هي في واقع الامر لا يمكن اخذها كمجرد
نسبه بل لابد ان ننظر الى هؤلاء الناخبين
يعني من هؤلاء الناخبين هم في واقي الامر
معارضون لارضوان ولكل في الوقت نفسه هم
كانوا يبحثون عن بديل جديد وهم من يصفون
انفسهم بانهم هم مناصرون
بانهم هم قوميون ايضا يعني خمسه فاصل
اثنين بالمئه من الاصوات اي ما يقارب
اثنين مليون
ناخب في واقع الامر نجد ان هذه الفئه ان
كانت تعارض اردوغان وتعارض في الوقت نفسه
الا ان معارضتهم لك اكثر من معرضتهم
لاردوغان وخاصه انهم ايضا يعارضون بان
يعني ان يكون حزب الجمهوري
المناصر لتركه والمتعه بانه حزب اتاتورك
ان يكون حزبا راضيا ربما
بسياسات امريكيه او بالتوجه نحو ما يمكن
ان نسميه بالانتداب الامريكي هذا الامر قد
ازعج هؤلاء في واقي الامر يعني
وبالتالي نجد في السياسات ايضا في عموما
في البحر وكذلك في سوريا والعمليات
العسكريه التي وقعت موجوده وقربه وغير ذلك
من الوسائل
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي من اسطنبول وشكرا
لسيده ديلك جابي الكاتبه الصحفيه والمحلله
السياسيه ضيفتنا من ازمير شكرا لكما
شكلت المحافظات التي ضربها زلزال السادس
من شباط فبراير الماضي في تركيا خزانا
انتخابيا واسعا لصالح تحالف الجمهور في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه وللرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في التقرير التالي قراءه في
توجهات الناخدين وخطابات الطرفين في
المناطق المنكوبه
سياسيا تعرف مناطق الزلزال بالتوجه
المحافظ وقد شهدت في العقدين الماضيين
تقدما في خدمات البنيه التحتيه وارتفع
مستوى الرفاهيه الاقتصاديه للسكان حضرت في
خطاب الرئيس ماده اساسيه
فوعد بسرعه بناء المنازل والمرافق التي
دمرت وبنقل مراكز انتاج وصناعات اساسيه
الى هذه المحافظات هذه الصور التقطناها في
اليوم التاسع للزلزال في كهرمان مرعش كان
مركز ايواء هذا شبه مكتمل لاستقبال السكان
الذين فقدوا منازلهم
اجروا مقارنه بين وعود الطرفين وراوا ان
تحالف الجمهور برئاسه اردوغان هو الاقدر
على انجاز وعوده فمعظم الولايات المتضرره
صوتت وفق توجهها تقليدي لصالح تحالف
الجمهور
حاولت المعارضه استماله ناخب مناطق
الزلزال بوعود التنميه ورفع معدلات
المداخيل لكن نتائج الاقتراع في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه والجوله الرئاسيه
الاولى لم تكن كما ارادت فتخلت المعارضه
عن مغازله الناخبين فيها بينما ضجه البلاد
بخطاب وصف بالعنصري تجاه النخبي
الاشخاص الذين شنوا هجوما على الناخبين لا
نعرفهم يقع على عاتق وزاره الداخليه
ملاحقتهم على هذه الاساءات ولكن ان يتهم
حزبنا بالتحريض على الناخبين فهذا امر
نرفضه ونستنكره فانا رئيس فرع حزب معارض
في كهرمان مراش وهذه الاساءات لحقت بي
ايضا وفي نظره على نتائج الدوره الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه تصدر اردوغان في ثمان
ولايات من اصل احدى عشره ولايه منكوبه
بينما اتت نتائجه متقاربه جدا مع تقدم
بسيط لمرشح المعارضه كليتشدار اوغلو فيها
تاي وفارق مريح لصالح الاخير في ديار بكر
وعظنه
في الجوله الثانيه قد تلعب خطابات
يعول اردوغان على وعود التنميه لرفع نسب
التصويت لصالحه وستحاول المعارضه التغلب
على اتهامات باعتماد خطاب عنصري ضد ناخبي
مناطق الزلزال سلام خضر الجزيره كهرمان
مراش
[موسيقى]
نعود الى التوتر في البلقان فالازمه بين
البان وصرب كوسوفو ليست الاولى وقد لا
تكون الاخيره فهي نتيجه احداث عنف سابقه
وعلاقات تاريخيه متوتره بين بريشتينا وبيل
جراند يعود تاريخ سبب التصعيد الاخير الى
الثالث والعشرين من ابريل الماضي عندما
قاطع نحو 50 الف صربي في شمال البلاد
الانتخابات البلديه برر المقاطعه بانها
احتجاج على عدم تلبيه مطالبهم لنيل حكم
ذاتي اكبر في البلديات التي تقع على حدود
صربيا تفجر الوضع ايضا في الحادي وثلاثين
من اكتوبر من العام الماضي بعد اصدار
البرلمان الكوسوفي قانونا يمنع استخدام
لوحات اجنبيه للسيارات ويلزم جميع السكان
بوضع لوحات سياره سيارات معت من الحكومه
في بريشتينا رفض السرب القانون وقاموا
باجراءات تصعيديه وقدم مسؤولون استقالات
جماعيه من كل الوظائف العامه في حين اعلن
رجال الشرطه من الصرب العصيانه المدني لا
تعترفوا صربيا باقليم كوسوفو الذي يشكل
الالبان اغلب سكانه واعلن استقلاله عنها
في عام 2008
ويرفض العديد من افراد الاقليه الصربيه في
كوسوفو وعددهم نحو 120 الفا يرفضون اعلان
ولائهم لبرشتينا
بتشجيعراد وخصوصا في شمال البلاد وقد
تغيرت تبعيه كوسوفو كغيرها من دول البلقان
بتغير القوى المسيطره على المنطقه فبعد
انتهاء الحرب العالميه الاولى اصبحت
كوسوفو ضمن مملكه يوغوسلافيا وخلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه تم ضمها الى البانيا
التي كانت تحت الاحتلال الايطالي وافق
الرئيس الراحل جوزيف بروستيتو سنه
1947 على منح كوسوفو حكما ذاتيا في اطار
اتحاد الجمهوريات اليوغوسلافيه وفي يونيو
من عام 1989 قام الزعيم الصربي سلوبودان
بيلوستيفيتش بزياره كوسوفو وطالب الصرب
بان لا ينسوا ما حدث قبل سته قرون ثم اعلن
الغاء الحكم الذاتي بدا الكوسوفيون نضالا
سياسيا سلميا للمطالبه بالاستقلال وشجعهم
على ذلك استقلال بعض مكونات يوغوسلافيا
السابقه بدءا من سلوفينيا وكرواتيا مرورا
بمقدونيا والبوسنه
هذا النضال حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الالباني برئاسه ابراهيم روجوفا الذي
انتخبه الكوسوفيون في مايو 1992 رئيسا
لجمهوريه كوسوفو المعلنه من طرف واحد وبلغ
الصراع ذروته سنه
1998 عندما قام الجيش الصربي بارتكاب
مجازر وحشيه ضد المدنيين الالبان وفي مارس
من عام
1999 شنت قوات النيتو هجوما على
يوغوسلافيا صربيا وجبل الاسود استمر 78
يوما لوقف الحرب في كوسوفو وفي السابع عشر
من فبراير 2008 اعلن البرلمان استقلال
دوله كوسوفو وكانت الولايات المتحده اول
من اعترف بهذا الاستقلال للمزيد ينضم
الينا من فيرجينيا السفير
ريتشاردش السفير الامريكي السابق في
البوسنه والهرتسك ونائب مساعدي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السابق للشؤون
الاوروبيه مرحبا بك سيد السفير هذه الازمه
بخلفيات تاريخيه صعبه ومعقده كيف تقرا ما
يحدث الان في كوسوف
اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى النظر الى ثلاثه
ابعاد حول ما يجري في غرب البلقان وصربيا
وكوزفو اولها هي ما حصل في كازا يوم امس
وسواء كان ذلك
محاوله للسيطره على بعض البلديات التي
قاومها الصرب
وايضا
وايضا اثار حفيظه وقلق الصربيين بعد اتفاق
استغرق عشر سنوات التوصل اليه بين صربيا
وكاذبه لتطبيعي العلاقات بينهما لكن
القياده السلبيه الحاليه لا يبدو انها
تريد القبول بالوضع كما هو عليه وهذا ما
يفسر التوتر الاوضاع بهذه الطريقه دخول
الناتو من جهه
وروسيا من جهه اخرى على خط هذه الازمه
النيتو يطالب السلطات في كوسوفه بخفض
التصعيد وروسيا تبدو انها داعمه للصرف
فيما يحدث
ومنذ اواخر التسعينيات
كان له وجود في قوصفه من خلال قوه الكيفور
او قوه حمايه
فاذا تورط النيتو ان صح التعبير موجود منذ
البدايه وعليه واجب ان يرفع صوته اذا ما
وقع عنف من هذا النار لان الوضع قد يخرج
النطاق السيطره اما روسيا ولاسباب خاصه
بها لقرب علاقتها مع صربيا ومع ايضا
تدخلها في البوسنه والهرسك من قبل هم
يحاولون ليس فقط
احلال التوازن ضد النيتو ولكن ايضا لتدعيم
نفوذهم في غرب البلقان لهذا السبب الازمه
تلوح في الافق اكثر فاكثر ما الحلول
المطروحه لهذه الازمه مع القوميه الصربيه
الضئيله في شمال كوسوفو كيف يمكن التعامل
مع مطالبها وما عدم اعترافها اساسا
بالدوله الكوسفيه
هذه كانت جذور المشكله منذ البدايه انا
امضيت سنتين
كثافيرات المتحده في البوسنه والهرسك
وهناك ايضا مشاكل مازلنا نواجهها حيث هناك
اقليات من السكان واغلبيات من السكان ما
يجعل من كازا اكثر صعوبه حتى من البوصله
والهرسك هو ان السكان ليسوا متركزين في
منطقه واحده او منطقتين فيصفح من الصعوبه
بمكان كما هو الحال في المدن في شمال
كوزوفو حيث
الاغلبيه القذافيه تصوت لعمد والرسائل
الذيات لا يقبلهم افراد الاقليه ولهذا
السبب هذه القضيه ان لم يتم التعامل معها
داخل
نفسها وبين ايضا
الرئيس والشعب الكوزوفي اللي خلق دعم كاف
لتطبيع العلاقه بين صربيا وبين كوسوفو لا
تنسوا ايضا ان هذه
الحرب هي ايضا هي قضيه سياسيه طبعا هناك
مشاكل ايضا داخل صربيا فهناك الالاف من
المظاهرات ضد الحكومه
وايضا صربيا واجهه الكثير من المشاكل
والكثير من انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان اذا
التطورات الداخليه في صربيا وما نراه في
ما يحدث في كوسوفو مرتبطه ببعضها البعض
اشكرك سفير ريتشارد كوزلو ريتش السفير
الامريكيه السابق في المستوى والهرسك
ونائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق لشؤون الاوروبيه
ضيفنا من فرجينيا
مشاهدينا الكرام وصلنا الى ختام حصاد هذه
الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم تصبحون على خير
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]